he is Mark Cuban here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you mark Goodrich how are
you it has got to be amazing to watch
this kid work man it's funny such a good
kid too I just love hanging out with him
he's again you know and he plays like
you're playing with a dude I playing
pickup at the Y and he's just having a
blast and everybody who plays with them
loves to play with them it's just
special to watch now when you walk me
through that that draft night trade mark
and and how that went how that worked I
mean were you nervous because I solved
another team and other players that had
yet to be drafted I mean well well there
was a couple things that had to happen
first you know there was the team's
ahead of us and you know typical in
draft every team kind of has a good feel
what the other teams are going to do but
you're never 100% certain so we thought
that number one would go John DeAndre
and to the Suns we weren't sure what the
Kings were going to do they ended up
selecting Marvin Bagley jr. and so then
we got on the phone and we had been on
the phone with the Hawks off and on
throughout the entire day and it was
like okay we got five minutes this
decision time and so we talked and went
back and forth and they came back we
wanted certain protections and we did
the negotiating and they basically said
you know this is the final offer you got
to say yes or no and I looked at Donnie
Nelson or GM and Rick Carlisle or coach
I'm like look if this good is this kid
is as good as we think is we're not
going to argue about protection for the
pick we just got to say yes we said yes
couple minutes later we were making the
pick and selected Luca and the rest is
history
well I mean and then obviously the rest
is indeed history but what made you
think that this kid is that special I
mean we'd been following him since he
was 16 years old I mean if not younger
with some of our scouts out in Europe
and everywhere he went he won I mean 16
17 18 years old he'd you know at 17 he
was playing against the OKC Thunder and
holding his own and he just he just had
that winner's mentality but he also has
the skill set to go with it and you know
I don't know that he's that LeBron
basketball IQ yet but he's approaching
that and that that plus his physical
abilities plus his willingness to work
and get better
there's willingness to learn
that that really just that entire
package just said okay we got to go for
them but you would would you turn him
ahead of schedule I mean is like right
none no I mean he showed us some things
last year but the work he put in because
he tailed off at the end of the year
last year I mean he wasn't used to the
grind of a 82-game schedule and so you
know we put it on him to work hard over
the summer that he couldn't be chubbier
than the owner and he had to get in
great shape and he did he took on every
challenge that we gave them he's you
know he's becoming more and more
discipline which is shocking for a
twenty-year-old
I mean Dirk was the most disciplined
player that I was ever around but at 20
when I first bought the team Dirk was
eating Snickers bars and chip you know
before and after games and and so Lucas
I think is picked up a little bit more
quickly and then Dirk did and that's a
big part of the equation I mean the dirt
lasted a long time for somebody that was
eaten like such yeah we learned very
quickly you know there's no more Venus
patrol and you know is Snickers bars on
the road and and so he got you know big
Dirk would not would not touch alcohol
would not eat sugar would not eat
anything fried for the last 15 years of
his career and Luke is not there yet but
he's taking those types of strides
forward well a couple more on this kid I
mean again cuz he's so special Mark
Cuban here on the Rich Eisen show the
fact that he did get to actually play
with Dirk for a year the fact that there
is a connective tissue do you think that
has anything to do with what we're
seeing right absolutely I mean he got to
see just how hard Dirk works just the
discipline that it took the way Dirk
interacted with fans so you know the way
Dirk carried himself you know because
he's still at 19 when he came in he's
still very impressionable even though
he'd been around man he'd been playing
professionally for years you know the
NBA is just a different beast for
everybody who comes in and so just being
able to see Dirk and his approach and
his work ethic and his discipline made a
huge difference and they still talk all
the time they do okay and then
he's delicate just 20 I mean we know you
know we live in a crazy world and the
NBA where where life comes at you fast I
mean do you have any plan is there any
plan in place to keep an eye on him or
anything out here no he's mature
I mean he's goofy but he's mature I mean
you know it's not like we have to keep
an eye on him you know he's settled down
in Dallas he's got a place got the
nutrition is that we work that he works
with he's got you know all the tools I
mean you know we try to take the
approach it's not just your body it's
not just your skills it's also your mind
it's also your nutrition you know and
give all of our players every edge that
we can give them and you know he's
really taken to it he's lifting weights
for the first time in his life I mean
it's he's really he's mature and he's
street-smart you know it's not like you
know book-smart where he's gone to
college but you can put him into any
situation and he knows what's going on
he's really a smart kid
Mark Cuban here on the Rich Eisen show
look I'm glad you're on on this show
mark because you know I do this show
every day but I'm also in the middle of
an NBA and NFL season with NFL Network
so you know on occasion it's tough for
me to do back-to-back shows I got load
managed yesterday so I'm glad that this
is the show you're on when you show I
did take a night off and back to back
you know I mean it's tough it's tough
you know so what gives
mark what gives with the whole load
management situation I mean these are
these are professionals that make a
living with their body and their you
know science has changed over the years
and we now are a lot smarter about the
impact of a 48 minute game you know we
can track fatigue we we can we can see
the impact not just in their on their
bodies but in their performance and so
when when we limit a guy's minutes we
get more out of them and not only that
but you know hopefully for the Mavs back
to the playoffs we we tend to balance it
out so our load management isn't just
reduction of minutes load management
also means towards the end of the season
you're increasing minutes you're
increasing number of games so that by
the time the playoffs kick in you're
ready for instead of playing 34th
35 minutes a game like Luca may be doing
right now ramping that up to 38 or 39
minutes so while everybody talks about
load management as being a reduction
step typically towards earlier in the
year but towards later in the year that
that load management means increasing
the number of minutes and being able to
take on a more strenuous load load so
take me behind the scenes here certainly
with your team are these dates already
predetermined before you even take the
floor to start the season that you did
this day that dates it's not know not
know so it depends on circumstances you
know did you have an overtime game was
it a tough game so he's playing you know
39 minutes instead of 34 minutes with
somebody injured so something else
changed though it's not preset where
okay here's the schedule we're sticking
to it it's very much contextual well
it's it's it's also not just about the
number of minutes that somebody's
playing on a certain night I mean I
don't think fans would care about that
because they're actually seeing the
player that many of them have spent
hard-earned American dollars and a lot
of planning on to see certainly if it's
just one time that they get to see a
certain star coming into their town so
what did what do you say to fans that
that hear the term load management when
they don't get to see one of the star
players in their town beats the heck out
of them being hurt and a bunch of teams
a bunch of fans not being able to see
them you know it's I mean you can just
see across the league that there was a
point in time when you know players
there were 10 15 players in the league
averaging 42 43 minutes or more
I think Allen Iverson you know had crazy
number of minutes that he played yeah
and it impacts their performance and it
leads to injuries and so you know on
would you rather you know even even if
you just we just come into an Eastern
Conference town and we do miss Lucca or
might have been Dirk or whoever for a
game you know I try to look at it from a
bigger picture and says you know it
might have been six games or eight games
or longer if you really got injured and
and injury levels are higher when you
don't pay attention to how much work the
guys putting in I think I know the
answer to it but I'm gonna ask it anyway
because I know you like going back and
forth and have a conversation and stuff
like this so obviously players can play
all 82
if the mentality of the membership and
also front office and also coaching
staff and and health and wellness staff
all says they're going into the season
where this guy's not gonna play eighty
two then why play 82 games oh I mean
those guys still want to get paid they
do get 52% of the revenue you know and
remember a big part what's the goal the
goal is to win a championship period end
of story
and if you're telling me that a guy
might miss a game on the back-to-back or
five games or six games very few players
play 82 games as it is right now and so
if somebody's playing 80 you know 74
games because the load management but
come playoff time
there are lots pressure their legs are
there they're there they're not as
dinged up as typically is the case now I
mean now you've got a better chance and
if you're playing in a series against
the team who hasn't taken that into
consideration then you have a huge
advantage hmm so are you are you load
managing I mean can you low manage a
twenty year old no you don't I mean but
again he's playing thirty four thirty
five minutes right you know but we do
try to get the right rotations so right
now he plays most of the first quarter
depending or yet most of the first
quarter depending on how things are
going in the game and who were playing
against that rotation may change
depending on the stretch of games we
have or you know who were playing
against you just the type of game that
it'll be so we just you know try to be
smart about it
there's definitely not one size fits all
okay to last two questions on this
subject does the player have any say in
it yeah yeah I mean we're gonna listen
to them but the players want to keep on
playing I mean they know what their
bodies feel like at the end of the year
and they know that when they feel
fresher they play better and again going
into the playoffs you want to be
physically at your best and that's what
matters more than anything and then the
last one is maybe you don't know the
answer I'd love if you did in your
perfect person ask who came up with the
term load management they did I have no
idea probably Shaq
is that because he is a larger to manage
I mean cuz that person deserves an award
of some kind to come up with a term yeah
I know you know what it was it might
have it was some team that put it on
there as excuse to the NBA but I don't
remember which one man so the larger
issue is well that will come up again
Draft time it always does is the concept
of when players should be allowed to
come out one and done etc and so on and
so forth what's your current I want on
all of us here mark in a perfect world
it'd be more like the NFL where you know
they play through their junior year and
that's more just because of life skills
more than anything else you know being
able to adapt to you know and I and I
recognize that the hypocritical nature
of that given that Luca would you know
just be a sophomore junior you know
right now but you know at the same time
we've had kids that don't know how to
open up a checking account don't know
how to you know sign a lease and you you
typically have to babysit them and
that's that's a challenge for me and
I've seen guys fall out of the league
because they just didn't have the life
skills now that said I don't expect that
to happen that I'm standing on an island
by myself and I really expected to go
from one and done to none and done and
kids will be coming out of high school
but that said a big impact on this is
going to be what happens with the NCAA
and and the rules on guys being able to
sell their image and being able to do
sponsors or however they define it
because it could easily I could easily
see a situation where you know a guy in
his freshman year wins a national title
and he's just killing it but it's not a
prototypical NBA player and might be you
know a bottom half of the first round or
early second-round player and he might
make more money staying in college and
so that could change the whole dynamic
of none and done how about that how do
you like the Omnibus coaching challenge
how that's gone so far but I still think
it's good
I think there's adjustments that need to
be made you know even when they get it
right because so often we have to move
it to a jump ball that still
disadvantaged
the team against which the call went was
wrong you know so we had a situation
where you know the ball went out of
bounds and so since he couldn't
ascertain whose possession it should
have been
we had a jump ball and that jump ball
went against us and we lost the game
against Portland
but it happened you know I'm always in
favor of getting the right in any way we
can and what's the house what's this
Shark Tank update here on the the most
successful business you bought and in
foster update for those who watch Sunday
nights on ABC every Sunday is that I
thought a company called - I sought it -
carvanha and it was called cyclorama
mmm it was a company that if you go to
carve on his website and you're able to
click on a car and spin it around open
the doors that's using some computer
computer vision libraries that they
created and so the company I think I
invested all in like $500,000 for 20%
and we sold it for like 25 million
dollars but the stock price of carvanha
keeps on going up and up and up so now
it's like a 70 million dollar deal so
we're all happy and then behind the
scenes which member of Shark Tank needs
to be load managed the most which ones
are wonderful we need a break from each
other
is that right because we had Kevin here
in studio Mike tell 2fo my audio
engineer or audio executive as he likes
to be called we had him pitch an idea
and mr. wonderful did his usual on on
Mike and just left him in a it was not a
very good idea
[Laughter]
Marc loved the chat thanks for the call
brother all the time really appreciate
it rich right back at you that's Marc
human owner of the Dallas Mavericks at M
Cuban I follow them on Twitter you
should as well same on Instagram for
more of the rich
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app